that is the concerns around the
coronavirus variant known as omacron
it's a strain confirmed in at least 19
countries and territories since it was
first reported in south africa last week
and officials say it remains unclear at
this hour whether symptoms are in fact
worse than previous strains like the
delta variant we're currently living
through on monday president biden warned
that the omicron variant will eventually
come here to america while also urging
all americans to remain calm
today there are three messages about the
new variant that i want the american
people to hear
first
this variant is a cause for concern not
a cause for panic
we're learning more about this new
variant every single day
and as we learn more we're going to
share that information with the american
people
candidly and promptly
all right the president also said
candidly and promptly that no widespread
new lockdowns are coming
he once again urged all eligible
americans to get vaccinated if they're
not already and the cdc now says get
boosted a booster shot is recommended
for all americans age 18 and older
we are joined now by dr francis collins
he's director of the national institutes
of health dr collins it's good to see
you thank you so much for joining us
this morning
glad to be with you gail nate and tony
yes thanks you know there is so much we
don't know we all know this is a very
fluid situation we don't know how
dangerous this variant is we don't know
if the vaccines are effective dr fauci
was here yesterday what do we know today
that we didn't know
yesterday well it's going to require a
little patience here to get the answers
because some of these are going to take
a couple of weeks to figure out where we
really stand
a pastor would say every
sermon has to have three points we have
three issues here we're trying to deal
with how contagious is omicron second
how severe is the disease that it can
cause and third do the current vaccines
provide protection
i think on the first point we know that
this is pretty contagious at least in
south africa because the cases are going
up rather steeply there in terms of how
severe it is only new information i saw
is some concern in south africa about
whether this is hitting young kids at a
higher level than previous
variants but that's very speculative we
don't really have rigorous data the big
question for most of us is do the
vaccines that have been put into a lot
of people's arms including mine do they
provide protection against this variant
the way they have with alpha and beta
and gamma and delta and we won't know
that for another couple of weeks so dr
collins it seems like there's two
categories of questions here there's the
how concerning is the variant and then
the other category is where is it now
i'm curious to know are there suspected
cases here in the u.s that our
government is currently looking at
not to my knowledge but i will not be
surprised if sometime in the next few
days we identify cases in the u.s
considering that this virus has found
its way already into a lot of countries
including our neighbors in canada it
would almost be surprising if we don't
have a case in the next week
dr collins as we gear up for 2022 most
of us we're looking forward to taking
the gear off and gear as in masks
does this variant mean that we could
possibly see more mandates and lockdowns
i don't think lockdowns are on the table
you heard the president talking about
that uh yesterday mask wearing yes i
mean we should be doing that anyway
all of our focus of course right now is
on omicron keep in mind delta is still
very much infecting people in the united
states today we are losing a thousand
people every day who died to this
condition most of them being
unvaccinated so all the things we should
be doing should be doing even more so
with the threat of this additional
variant that may come to our shores yeah
well dr collins so so much is not clear
at this hour that i'm hoping we can give
some
clarity to people holding hotel
reservations and plane tickets and
family plans for the next few weeks
looking at christmas and the new years
what is your advice from a medical
perspective to people
planning to travel or gather in the
weeks ahead
well i think to watch closely and see
how this develops over the coming days i
don't anticipate that the u.s is going
to clamp down additional travel
restrictions like they have with those
eight countries in south africa but keep
in mind if you're an international
traveler coming back to the u.s you are
required to be vaccinated and you are
required to have a test within one to
three days before you get on the plane
and last question dr collins would you
say if you don't have the booster you're
not fully vaccinated
that it's not effective i think we got
to be careful about the term yeah i got
to be careful about the terminology
fully vaccinated still means you've got
two doses of pfizer moderna or one dose
of jnj but if you want to be fully
protected against
delta and against whatever omicron might
offer us as far as a threat that booster
really helps it bumps up your antibody
levels and it broadens the range of
viruses that you can be protected
against in ways that reflect the
cleverness of your immune system if you
just give it that little encouragement
which is what the booster is so i know
but i keep hearing i keep hearing if you
haven't if you're past the six to eight
month mark of your second dose and two
months after j and j it's no longer
effective
true that's no that's not true it has
waned in its effectiveness it's not as
effective as it was at the beginning and
it can be a lot more effective if you
get the booster but it's not like it
went away it just got a little weaker
okay okay well no one wants to be weaker
thank you thank you very much thank you
nobody wants that thank you all